Trump has been caught lying he was not
being audited by the IRS in the way that
he claimed to be this so far we haven't
yet gotten the tax returns themselves
but we will based on the house Ways and
Means Committee vote yesterday we're
going to get the tax returns within a
few days maybe by the end of this week
maybe over the weekend maybe by the
start of next week and we will deal with
that but one of the big takeaways is
that the IRS mandatory audits for Trump
when he became president were
essentially non-existent Trump lied
Sarah Huckabee Sanders lied and so many
of them lied let's go back to we looked
at some of this clip earlier
um Congressman Lloyd Doggett explained
Trump was not being audited I hope I'm
roughly at the right moment here uh
let's see exactly where we are here we
go 2015 through 2020 just to be clear
that's correct okay and I think what uh
I find surprising this Focus had been on
the IRS audit and whether it was being
done properly is the IRS did no audits
at all until such time as the day they
received Mr Neal's request for these
documents and that day they requested
the first audit they have yet to
complete a single audit of Mr Trump and
I think they'll also be surprised by
what's not there with the tax returns
and that is supporting data any uh
taxpayer who goes in for audit has to
produce some receipts and some
affidavits and some substantiation and
that just seems to be missing from what
we've been providing that is absolutely
fascinating so even what they have
obtained it seems as though they really
haven't gotten the full data here is a
congressman Richard Neal who chairs the
house Ways and Means Committee expanding
on this we argued for an examination of
how the audit process played out
once
staff went to visit the IRS
at once staff had a chance to go to some
of the other locations that are within
the jurisdiction of the IRS
they quickly concluded that in fact
the audit did not occur there were no
audits in a timely manner and that goes
I think for 2017 2018 and 2019 and I'm
restrained by with the speech and debate
clause from talking about the other
issue that we uh
had on our agenda so the mandatory
initiative it highlights the idea that
it's sort of a two-tiered system if you
are at the top you really have no chance
of getting audited and as Steve Horsford
pointed out today in our our
get-together of the democratic caucus on
the committee your chances of being
audited if you claim the Earned Income
Tax Credit are far better than being
audited for people with the very top of
the economic system now that's an entire
other story we should talk about but
this claim that the IRS is targeting
Rich conservatives certainly does not
appear to be true and that's a bigger
story as a reminder here is Donald Trump
claiming that everything is under audit
and it's also complicated nobody would
understand it anyway this was at the end
of 2018 already
go ahead
he gave me a fair interview the other
day so I might as well ask him a
question all right thank you Mr
President and picking up there you told
me the other day that you are an open
book so I think I am an open book so
Point Blank Democrats go after your tax
returns will you try to block that or
will you
allow them now well look uh as I've told
you they're underwater they have been
for a long time they're extremely
complex I wouldn't understand them
they're done by among the biggest and
best law firms in the country same thing
with the accounting firms the
accountants are a very very large
powerful firm from the standpoint of
respect extremely powerful from the
standpoint of respect don't forget that
be respected big firm
big and wide firm girthy a great law
firmware you would you know it very well
they do these things they put them in
but people don't understand tax returns
you know I did do a filing of over 100
pages I believe which is in
the offices and when people went and saw
that filing and they saw the magnitude
of it they were very disappointed and
they cried and they said sir there's so
many pages in such font well the you
know the details you'd get far more from
that and I guess we filed that down
three times but you get far more from
that than you could ever get from a tax
return but when you're under audit and
I'm on a very continuous audit because
there are so many companies and it is a
very it's like a Mobius strip of audits
quite frankly big
company far bigger than you would even
understand it's a bigger company than
you've got Jim it's a it's a great
company but it's big and it's complex
and it's uh probably feet high it's a
very complex instrument and I think that
uh people wouldn't understand it but I
don't know if a tax return is an
instrument but okay so there was Trump
talking about even if it's all under
audit continuous audit and it's too
complicated for you to even understand
and then here was uh then press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders also
making similar claims
here on taxes you said I think we met on
Tuesday that as long as his taxes are
under on it he's not going to release
them his 2016 taxes to our knowledge are
not under audit unless they are uh my
understanding uh and I will double check
but the president's taxes no matter who
the president is actually immediately go
under audit things are being filed so
that's actually wasn't happening though
were you an accurate I'll double check
to be one so my question
so lies after lies after lies so I think
the strategy here
first we need to see what we learned
from the tax returns and that may modify
the strategy but absent the content
remember he said he would release his
tax returns when Obama releases his
birth certificate or whatever the birth
certificate we had the tax returns he
blocked he was going to release his
taxes if he won the presidency he won
the presidency in 2016 didn't release
the tax returns once the audits were
finished he was going to release him
turns out there weren't actually audits
going on so it's lie upon lie upon lie
we're going to get them we're going to
get them soon soon and we're going to
learn all about it folks Friday we are
two days away
from an incredible David Pacman Show
event we are doing
an end of the year membership special
where your first month's payment and
this applies to gifted memberships as
well will be donated
to an organization that sends cash to
people who need it one of the most
efficient ways of helping people is
actually sending them cash so they can
decide what for themselves what they
most need your first month's payment on
Friday if you use the coupon code we're
going to be creating
will be donated and doubled we're going
to be doubling the first fifteen
thousand dollars all you need to do to
be ready for Friday
is go to davidpackman.com
top right of the page it'll there's like
a box where you put in your email
address to get on our newsletter get on
our newsletter Friday morning you will
get instructions for how to sign up at a
discount we donate that first payment
and it gets doubled the first fifteen
thousand dollars incredible stuff we'll
take a quick break and be right back
You Love non-fiction books you love
learning as much as you can about
politics and economics and history and
science but you just don't have the time
to read every book that you want to read
that's why I'm such a big fan of
blinkist it's the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
them down into an explainer that you can
read or listen to in 15 minutes and get
the most important insights from the
book you take a topic you've been
wanting to explore and you can consume
10 books about it in an afternoon it
gives you a meaningful overview and
insight into what other books you might
want to read in full I just read welcome
to the universe it's Neil deGrasse
Tyson's latest book that's exactly the
type of book that I would love to have
the time to read but my stack of books
is already so big my girlfriend and I
also use the blinkist connect feature to
share and discuss books with one another
with one account and it makes a great
late last minute holiday gift you can
try blinkist free for seven days and get
25 off a subscription at blinkist.com
Pacman the link is down below